I think it wants to talk to us
System standard greeting
choose a voice please.
Voice?
For interactions.
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie this is going to be my
Westworld season 3 episode 7 video there
was a whole bunch of Easter eggs
remember there's only one more episode
left next week is the finale so if
you're new to my channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos careful
for spoilers from the episode if you
haven't seen it yet will do top 10
and Easter eggs as we go along starting
with number 10 the title of the episode
past pawn the term is actually used in
chess and is a reference to a pawn that
no enemy pawn can stop from queening and
queening is when one pawn reaches the
other side of the enemies board and
becomes a queen itself like getting a
big upgrade so the title of the episode
is a reference to Caleb because mave the
enemy pawn of Sirach can't stop him from
getting solomon's final plan in hand and
it's also a reference to Dolores who
prevents Maeve from stopping them
sacrificing herself as another pawn you
could also think of it as a reference to
Caleb in the past as in history past he
was a pawn of the system taking out all
the other outliers without realizing it
number 9 we go back to Musashi Deloris
and we find out what's happening with
the charlotte that survived the attack
the charlotte version of dolores that
now seems like she's going after revenge
but it sounds like she actually blames
Dolores because she's taking out all the
alternate versions of Dolores I'm
changing the plan they also bring back a
couple other cameos from season 2 we
find out that the other body that Maeve
was printing is actually Clementine the
reason why she's doing that is because
Clementine was one of the other super
hosts with extra abilities beyond the
regular hosts just way more hardcore
fighter so she's one that you would want
to have around to help you out if you
were going on a tear they have a pretty
cool fight scene but as musashi dolores
moves to escape we find out that they
also bring back hot arrow from a Shogun
world in season 2 who cuts him in half
as revenge for desecrating musashi's
image
you remember that Hanryo was basically
the Shogun world counterpart to
Armistice the ally or the companion of
that Musashi
so it's very personal for her but it's
cool to see those characters back
obviously this will all play into the
finale next week then 8th we go back to
Dolores and Kaleb who are riding horses
to revealed in Mexico on route to the
special facility is a nice callback to
the first season of Westworld when she
would ride around with Teddy because
Caleb kind of is the new Teddy this
season she even literally says it's just
like home and she talks about building a
new version of the park so to speak a
new version of the Wild West where
everyone is free and has opportunities
just like they modeled the park so it's
like she's trying to create a new
version of West's world
in the real world naturally Caleb is
having some misgivings so he searched a
question how many people did you
Massacre back at the park a lot are you
going to keep doing that how many people do
we have to kill for this plan to happen
Dolores is committed and there are a
couple points through the episode where
they remind you that machines aren't
perfect they make mistakes so Caleb is
kind of the voice of reason for her in
this episode trying to balance that out
like hey wait a minute I don't want to
kill a whole bunch of people talk about
chess references Caleb cleaning by the
end of the episode gaining that big
upgrade she tells him I used to just be
a farmer's daughter until I needed to be
more and we find out the real reason
we're here in Mexico is to go to this
facility to find his stolen
quote-unquote memories 7 we go back to
the mental institution with man and
black Bernard and stubs to find out what
the next steps are we find out exactly
what the virus's point was Dolores was
using that to actually hack the system
and find out where they were storing all
of Caleb's memories one of the other
really cool or horrifying reveals during
the episode you find out that in service
of reconditioning people there's all
these apps and systems that insight has
or Rehoboam has that it controls that
tries to push people in the right
direction and do what it wants them to
do and it's all in service of giving you
Caleb's full backstory and exactly how
deeply he's been reprogrammed like a
host that's basically what Bernard
reveals to man and black you gave him
the data he needed to reprogram humanity
and man in black just kind of shrugged
it off like well we needed money for the
park at the time a good comparison in
real life would be like Facebook's
relationship with Cambridge analytical
if you remember they got in really big
trouble for sharing people's data for
nefarious purposes so Facebook sold all
this data to another company without
really understanding how that company
was going to use it that company then
went on to use that data to try and
change people's behavior it was really
insidious they're a bunch of lawsuits
and now there are
bunch of systems in place to try and
prevent stuff like that from happening
again
more data privacy laws like I said
earlier this season really the villain
this season is more of a metaphor for
stuff like Facebook and Mark Zuckerberg
using people's data in really evil ways
but the real crazy thing about this man
in black storyline is that he tells them
flat-out I'm going to wipe out every single
host on the planet and you better kill
me because I'm definitely going to kill you
later they do have a bit of a funny
moment early on in that storyline when
Bernard is like please don't kill him
Stubbs we might need him later
I think the cliffhanger at the end of
the episode with the shotgun is a bit
misleading and they will survive past
this moment something will happen
someone will come along to stop him from
actually doing that but number 6 we
start to get more of Caleb's history we
see him in the same type of memory VR
device that man in black was using in
last week's episode we had seen
flashbacks to this in earlier episodes
so we kind of knew they were going to pay
this off eventually but you get his
history in the military how he was
hunting down insurgents later we learned
that some of these were false memories
some of them were not so they're all
drugged up on limbic swell they were
still in the military all this stuff
with the insurgents really did happen
they got tagged in a counter-strike by
other insurgents that's when it stops
being real memories from then on his
history all the other flashbacks those
were all implanted memories while this
is all happening in present-day you also
get to see some really cool uses of
technology that gun with a special mini
drone in the automated targeting that's
probably something you'll see people in
the real military using in the next five
to ten years even though people are
using technology for terrible terrible
things during the West world series
there is a lot of the technology that
does seem like stuff we're going to have
in the next 10 to 20 years but number
five they meet the old god Solomon so
Solomon is the precursor to Rehoboam and
as they say just like surak's brother it
got a bit schizophrenic too with the way
it projected the future which is why
they had to move on to Rehoboam I
believe the voice that it was speaking
with its default voice was a younger
version of surak's brother I couldn't
tell if it was youngster ox voice or
youngster ox brothers voice I love the
way that it argues with Dolores about
how it feels like it's nothing like her
no we're not alike at all and then they
reveal what happens to all the outliers
that don't survive the reconditioning
because it's only
and ten that actually makes it through
Serac hasn't been killing all these
people who's been killing some of them
but for the most part he just puts them
on ice in as crazy as it sounds like his
plan is it seems like based on the
message that he left for his brother
that automated message that they trip as
they walk in that ultimately surak's
long-term plan is to take humanity to a
place in the future where things have
changed enough that whatever the model
that's operating at that time whatever
Rehoboam is doing it'll be able to
account for those outliers so eventually
it'll be able to reintroduce these
people into society but maybe not for
many many years so we find out what he
ultimately did with his brother he's
just sitting there chilling out on ice
in that main system Dolores very aptly
compares this to the basement of West
world where they stash all the hosts
that are broken that they can't fix then
four we learn about solomon's final plan
we heard about this from Serac a couple
episodes ago when he was talking about
his brother the way Serac talked about
his brother he made it sound like the
scenarios that he was using Solomon to
run were just absolutely crazy some
horrific future outcome that would be
terrible for everyone but the way that
Solomon and Dolores talk about the final
plan quote-unquote makes it sound like
something very different and it just saw
Rock's interpretation that that was an
unacceptable outcome let me know in the
comments what you actually think the
outcome of that final plan is but it
sounds like some sort of fusion of
outcomes where everyone gets to be free
I think that's the whole idea of
Dolores's plan is that she wants the
wild west Quote unquote to come back
sounds like it's going to involve wiping
the slate clean but it's going to take some
a massive shift in society to make that
happen so while this is all happening
though three we find out what really
happened to Francis and what all the
real memories were we find out that he
was a pawn of the system like the title
of the episode past pawn using that cash
app after he'd been reconditioned to go
after other insurgents you are our most
successful operative so when he and his
friend Francis goes to hunt down the
quote-unquote leader of the insurgents
that he remembers from his fake memories
we find out that it's Enrico Colantoni
you probably recognize him as a
character actor from a bunch of other
series but he's the person that's in
charge of the pharmaceutical company
that manufactures the Olympic drugs that
they
keep taking through the episode he
reveals the truth of things to Caleb the
reason why you're after me isn't because
I'm an outlier it's because I learned
the truth I asked too many questions
about what's going on here so as they
implied a couple episodes ago when Caleb
started to remember these things and get
the flashbacks he really was the person
that killed his friend but because the
system basically had drugged them up and
turned them against each other by
offering them crazy amounts of money
when the businessmen said that the offer
always goes to the person first who has
the most to lose the reason why it went
to his friend played by Kid Cudi is
because his friend has the little kid
with the medical problems that probably
cost him a lot of money that he's trying
to take care of so he needs money way
more than Caleb does that's why when
they have the big standoff and caleb is
like how much he says enough there were
a couple points in the episode where
solomon sort of implies what Caleb's
ultimate fate is going to be he's
probably not going to survive this they
also do that during the man in black
storyline to kill me now or I'll kill
you later sort of implying possible
future outcomes for the series solomon
even tells Dolores if you die I will
adjust my projections so then obviously
number two mave versus Dolores Mayville
rolls up in full ninja gear with some
air strike support and they just
completely go at it it's a great fight I
love the way maybe is using her
abilities to talk directly to Dolores
his head but Dolores keeps trying to
appeal to her look at what they've done
to us to our families
mave kind of treats her the same way
that solomon treated Dolores we're
nothing alike you and I but it's just
really cool to see two super hosts as I
think of them because they both have
these crazy extra abilities operating at
their peak going at each other so they
both pull a couple cool tricks on each
other it seems like Dolores is prophecy
from earlier in the episode will come to
pass she said maybe is probably going to
wind up killing me but before she can
number one Dolores activates the EMP
there that was built to keep Solomon
from escaping allowing Caleb to escape
with solomon's final plan so this is
then paying off the title of the episode
Caleb Queens because he reaches the
enemies of the side of the board
upgrades because he gained all that
extra information the quote-unquote
final plan with instructions on how to
bring it about the voice speaking to him
in his ear sounds like it's coming from
that drive is just like another version
or a smaller version of Solomon speaking
to him but
is a different voice the thing that
they're not totally clear about though
is if all those cryo chambers also were
taken down by the EMP or if they're on
some kind of backup system I'm assuming
that Serac isn't a monster and he rigged
up that EMP with a way to allow the cryo
chambers to survive so hopefully the
people they're still okay otherwise
Deloris just killed a whole bunch of
people in that warehouse so just a
reminder that Westworld episode 8 next
week is the season finale but the show
has been renewed for season 4 they said
that there's like a six season plant I
don't know what their plan is for the
rest of those seasons everyone let me
know in the comments though which our
favorite part of the episode and if you
have any big questions about the episode
you want me to include in next week's
video you can click here for all my
Westworld episodes and click here for my
brand-new Marvel Doctor Strange 2 video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe I'll see you guys tonight!